yeah welcome to this video play French
defense here against MN cm 7 8 9 and I
play this game all blind which I pretty
much have to work out here off with the
board hmm is it f 66 is probably one
possible line this is already quite nice
for black I get to play you five very
early on threatening you for maybe you
can cancel make a piece heck out of it I
don't know my development the Sun
obviously lagging yeah but if it takes
only five I certainly have a good
position
95 comes with kempo on the bishop so
taking de 595 attacking d3 I didn't look
good this line already em looks very
comfortable for black
he goes to see two I wonder about Bishop
to g4 isn't this good he's pretty much
forced to play f3 then and then maybe
Bishop to c5 looks excellent very active
hmm Quincy to ya know I can get a fine
position with more than one one line I
can also just take Jack and consider
Queenie five after which she pretty much
has to play Queenie too yeah so check
simple but just strong check leading to
a bishop our position where i also have
an extra bone in the center
check Knight f3 25 if this is this is a
bit a bit of a problem
rook e8 I want to play a quick look here
so that 95 is not coming it is not so
quickly
now this was likely not the best move
hmm yeah bishop age 42 g3 now or 95
coming hmm yeah its own just check just
nothing unfortunately can I not take it
there some way to avoid the capture to
try to a two in the game I can play King
Jade can try that taking it it is of
course just the draw
not so bad is in the pin here I can play
maybe um yeah let's get going it doesn't
really have a square for the night
g-form maybe but this isn't no no it's
not really a square I mean they can I
can just take it by the time you take on
you one take on g4 damage the structure
yeah this is some quite nice for black
hmm how to add to suggest them a
defensive set up he wants to play Knight
to c4
should I play b5 now maybe if you are
going to win maybe just prevent Nazi
form
now look trust the check all
hmm
that's a one double ugh CH but probably
this is this is nonsense
but I can Jenna can take
here just protect this a 7 and d4 and
then playfully should be one and I but
he's got he's got a for ya and before
yeah this didn't help at all
yeah it's probably just the drawn so
something better than taking on everyone
see six with the drawing probably not on
there are our third
okay yeah I offered to draw here
so rather pointless to play on but
nothing I can do about it
this is very very debt opposite call it
the bishops endgame I have the wrong
Alfred okay are drawn okay so a draw
here this is really too little after the
opening I'm check I really hate this
battling check here after that I really
missed time the plane c5 and be sure to
d6 was probably bad yeah I'm really
substantially better but I need to make
sure that I keep the the bishops maybe I
should prefer something like it should
be seven type of setup like c6 Bishop e7
it's mainly may be the better choice to
keep them here like this and then play
just here may be here to to make sure
that the bishops are not exchanged the
way it is played um like he always has
this idea to X to exchange the bishop
and I've got e5 weekend so check so it's
very difficult to make any prior tried
but I didn't make make much headway this
this looks nice for black but i didn't i
didn't really managed to get something
the computer wants to play with c4 this
is actually an interesting idea our
black gets okay here for sure I didn't
didn't make any any progress though now
maybe maybe I also have something better
here in the opening 93 is good of course
leading to talk like edge but I could
also just to just play a normal move
like this and if he for into the via
castle said something like Queen edge
force already already very very
dangerous
hmm so this was an excellent opening
result for black all right thanks for
watching